estemos aquí utilizando una hoja de
cálculo podrías estar utilizando
microsoft excel o podrías estar usando
una hoja de cálculo de google drive pero
bueno por aquí tenemos una población de
estudiantes estas son sus edades y
queremos calcular algunos parámetros y
después de calcular los también vamos a
observar qué pasa si modificamos un poco
los datos por ejemplo qué pasa si le
sumamos cierta cantidad o si los
multiplicamos por alguna otra cantidad
lo que pasa con estos parámetros que
vamos a calcular pero bueno el primer
parámetro que vamos a calcular es la
media luego también vamos a calcular la
desviación estándar también quiero que
calculemos la mediana y el rango inter
cuartil para ver aquí vamos a hacer una
abreviación ok por aquí estamos
abreviando desviación estándar y aquí
estamos abreviando el rango inter
cuartil pero bueno hagamos esto quiero
empezar por las medidas de tendencia
central
esas son la media y la mediana para
encontrar la media ponemos un igual y
ponemos promedio en inglés que es
average algunas veces tenemos la opción
de utilizar el nombre en español de
estas funciones por ejemplo aquí
podríamos poner promedio en lugar de
average pero en este vídeo vamos a
utilizar los nombres en inglés porque
hay algunos otros programas en los que
no se puede usar el nombre en español y
queremos calcular el promedio de todos
estos datos pero ahora nos podemos poner
a pensar qué pasaría con la media si
tomara todos estos datos y le sumara
alguna cantidad por ejemplo si tenemos
aquí todos los datos y decido sumarle 5
una forma muy fácil de hacer todo esto
es poner un signo de igual seleccionar
la celda anterior ya ésta sumarle 5 que
hay 12 10 7 5 y después nos vamos a la
esquina hasta que aparece esta cruz y
jalamos hasta donde queremos que se haga
esa función ahora
todos estos datos son los mismos datos
que teníamos aquí pero más 5 ok este es
nuestro nuevo conjunto de datos al que
le estoy llamando datos + 5 y ahora
veamos cuál es la media de este nuevo
conjunto de datos y aquí podemos
observar qué es exactamente 5 más y
hubiera sucedido exactamente lo mismo se
hubiera sumado arrestado por alguna otra
cantidad la media del nuevo conjunto de
datos sería la media anterior más o
menos la misma cantidad que le sume o
reste al conjunto de datos y eso no
debería de sorprendernos tanto porque
cuando estamos sacando la media lo que
hacemos es sumar todos los datos y
dividir esa suma entre el número de
datos que tenemos entonces si le sumamos
5 a todos los datos a la hora de sacar
la media estamos sumando 5 por la
cantidad de datos que tenemos que en
este ejemplo en particular es 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10
12 así es que con esto de que le sumamos
5 a cada uno de los datos a la hora de
calcular la media estamos sumando 5 unas
12 veces más pero luego tenemos que
dividir entre 12 entonces globalmente
estamos simplemente sumando 5 y por lo
tanto la media del nuevo conjunto de
datos es simplemente 5 unidades más que
la media original pero bueno también
vamos a hacer otro ejemplo interesante
vamos a ver qué pasa si multiplicamos
todos los datos por 5 entonces aquí
ponemos un igual seleccionamos el dato
original y lo multiplicamos por 5 y le
decimos a nuestra hoja de cálculo que
haga lo mismo con todos los datos ahora
cada uno de estos datos es 5 por el dato
original y ahora veamos qué pasa con la
media podemos observar que ahora la
media es la media que teníamos al
principio pero por 5 esto lo que nos
está diciendo es que las medidas de
tendencia central x
la media si le sumamos o restamos una
cantidad a los datos la media aumenta o
disminuye exactamente esa cantidad y lo
mismo sucede con la multiplicación si
hacemos un escalamiento de los datos por
5 o entre 5 la media también es
amplificada por 5 o entre 5 y por
supuesto si observáramos numéricamente
como calculamos la media podríamos
observar que esto tiene todo el sentido
del mundo matemáticamente pero empecemos
por observar qué pasa con la otra medida
de tendencia central la mediana la otra
medida típica de tendencia central
cuando le sumamos una cantidad a todos
los datos o cuando multiplicamos todos
los datos por alguna otra cantidad vamos
a empezar calculando la mediana de los
datos y esto lo hacemos así para
nosotros calcular la mediana lo que
tendríamos que hacer es ordenar estos
datos y encontrar cuál es el dato de en
medio nosotros nos tardaríamos bastante
tiempo pero la computadora lo puede
hacer
muy rápido así es que esta es la mediana
de los datos tu cual te imaginas que va
a ser la mediana de los datos más 5
bueno pues si ordenamos estos números y
nos fijamos en el de en medio tenemos la
mediana pero si además a todos estos
números le sumamos 5 a la hora de que
los ordenemos nos van a quedar con el
mismo orden pero cuando nos fijemos en
el dato de en medio simplemente va a
tener 5 más
entonces la mediana de los datos más 5
debería de ser 10 puntos 5 y así es y
ahora también nos podemos preguntar qué
pasa si tomamos todos los datos y los
multiplicamos por 5 la mediana como se
comporta en ese caso
bueno pues estos datos aunque los
multiplicamos por 5 deberían de tener el
mismo orden por lo que la mediana de los
datos por 5
ser la mediana de los datos multiplicada
por cinco veamos en efecto eso es lo que
tenemos aquí así es que estas dos
medidas de tendencia central si le
sumamos o restamos alguna cantidad la
medida aumenta o disminuye exactamente
esa misma cantidad y también
simplificamos todos los datos
multiplicando los por alguna cantidad
las dos medidas de tendencia central
también se amplifican multiplicándose
por exactamente la misma cantidad bueno
pero ahora vamos a ver estas dos medidas
de dispersión y vamos a ver si sucede lo
mismo con ellas así es que empezamos
calculando la desviación estándar esto
lo que hace es calcular la desviación
estándar de una población suponemos que
esta es toda nuestra población esta es
nuestra desviación estándar y ahora
vamos a ver qué pasa con la desviación
estándar si a todos los datos le sumamos
5 aunque bueno más bien ponle una pausa
a este vídeo y piensa en que debería de
pasar con la vez
standard esta es una medida de
dispersión porque yo te voy a decir todo
lo que yo pienso bueno pues ya todos los
datos los desplazamos sumándole 5 es
cierto la media tiene que cambiar y
tiene que cambiar 5 unidades pero la
dispersión no porque la distancia de
cada uno de los datos a la media tiene
que seguir siendo exactamente la misma
porque a todos los estamos desplazando
la misma cantidad así es que la
desviación estándar no debe de cambiar
nada y en efecto no está cambiando nada
así es que si tenemos un conjunto de
datos y lo desplazamos a todos los
valores por la misma cantidad ya sea
hacia arriba o hacia abajo es cierto la
medida de tendencia central tiene que
cambiar pero la medida de dispersión se
tiene que quedar exactamente igual y es
lo que estamos viendo aquí bueno aunque
aquí nada más estamos viendo que la
desviación estándar no cambia
ahora una pregunta más interesante es
qué pasa si tomamos el conjunto de datos
y lo amplificamos multiplicando por
cinco ahora nos estamos preguntando qué
pasa con la desviación estándar con ese
cambio yo pienso que tiene mucho sentido
que la medida de dispersión no cambie si
simplemente sumamos o restamos algún
número sin embargo si estamos
multiplicando por otro número ahora sí
tiene todo el sentido del mundo que
cambie porque si nos fijamos en este
conjunto de datos dos datos que se
encontrarán a cierta distancia si
multiplicamos todos los datos por cinco
ahora esos datos están cinco veces más
alejados entre sí y lo mismo sucede con
la media ahora todos los datos como
estamos multiplicando todo por 5 ahora
todos los datos van a estar cinco veces
más alejados de la media de lo que
estaban entonces yo pienso que la
desviación estándar ahora en este nuevo
conjunto de datos
tienen que ser cinco veces más grande a
ver vamos a ver qué pasa
si parece como que estamos multiplicando
por 5
entonces simplificamos un conjunto de
datos la desviación estándar también se
amplifica por esa misma cantidad bueno
pero qué pasa con el rango inter cuartil
pasará lo mismo para calcular el rango
inter cuartil lo que hacemos es primero
calcular el primer cuartil y el tercer
cuartel y tomar la resta entre esos dos
cuarteles y bueno para calcular el rango
inter cuartil tenemos una función
primero seleccionamos los datos y
después indicamos cuál cuartil queremos
ok entonces vamos a seleccionar los
datos ponemos una coma y decimos que
queremos el tercer cuartel cerramos
paréntesis y aquí el dato que tenemos es
cuál es el tercer cuartel de estos datos
pero si queremos el rango inter cuartil
tenemos que tomar el tercer cuartel
y restarle el primer cuartil queremos el
mismo conjunto de datos pero esta vez
queremos el primer cuartil que yo
ponemos una coma y un 1 y listo
este es nuestro rango inter cuartil en
esta parte calculamos el tercer cuartel
en esta parte calculamos el primer
cuartil y estamos restando los y
obtenemos 2.75 como nuestro rango inter
cuartil de este conjunto de datos bueno
y ahora podemos ponernos a pensar en si
el rango inter cuartil cambia si a todos
los datos le sumamos 5 yo estoy segura
de que no cambian nada porque es cierto
que el primer cuartil va a valer 5 más
pero el tercer cuarto y también va a
valer 5 más entonces a la hora de restar
los nos va a quedar exactamente lo mismo
nos va a quedar 2.75 en efecto aquí el
rango inter cuartil no cambió nada pero
ahora tenemos que pensar en qué pasa si
a todos los datos los multiplicamos por
5 y ahora
ahora si el rango inter cuartil va a
cambiar porque si multiplicamos todo por
5 el primer cuartil va a estar
multiplicado por cinco el tercer cuartel
también va a estar multiplicado por
cinco y por lo tanto estamos
multiplicando por cinco a toda esta
resta así es que veamos qué pasa en fin
lo que podemos aprender de este
ejercicio es que ok bueno aquí estamos
sumando 5 y multiplicando por cinco pero
podríamos haber sumado o multiplicado
por cualquier número también sabemos que
la media y la mediana que son nuestras
medidas de tendencia central si
desplazamos o amplificamos nuestros
datos estas dos medidas se van a
desplazar y multiplicar por el mismo
factor pero nuestras típicas medidas de
dispersión la desviación estándar y el
rango inter cuartil no cambian aunque
desplazas los datos pero definitivamente
si cambian cuando amplificamos los datos
o que cuando los multiplicamos o
dividimos por algún factor
se amplifican con el mismo factor con el
que estamos amplificando los datos